[موسيقى]
الاتهامات الجنائيه ليست وحدها التي
يواجهها ترامب فالتحقيقات معه متعدده
ومختلفه
الهجوم على الكابيتول لجنه برلمانيه حققت
في دوري ترامب في الهجوم على مبنى
الكونغرس في السادس من يناير 2021
واوسط بان يطلق القضاء الفيدرالي ملاحقه
ضده
انتخابات 2020 في جورجيا مدعيه عامه تحقق
في محاولات التاثير على العمليه
الانتخابيه في هذه الولايه التي فاز فيها
بايدن بفارق ضئيل
ارشيف البيت الابيض احتفظ ترامب بوثائق
مصنفه سريه ومن الممكن اصدار لائحه اتهام
فيدراليه في هذا الاطار
قضايا ماليه في نيويورك فرض على منظمه
ترامب في نيويورك دفع غرامه تصل قيمتها
الى مليون و600 الف دولار بتهمه الاحتيال
المالي والضريبي للمجموعه التي تنتظر
محاكمه مدنيه اكبر في الخريف
[موسيقى]